une fois par semaine ces vins bédard un
greffé du coeur connecte son
défibrillateur sur un modem qui transmet
les informations stockées sur son
appareil vers le terminal d'une
entreprise installée à londres la
compagnie suit devraient aviser mais
cliniciens si un problème si j'ai trop
fait d'arythmie aussi j'ai fait des à
des alertes ou si j'ai eu des anomalies
pendant la semaine terminée les
vérifications régulières à la clinique
de défibrillateurs sylvain bédard et
maintenant autonome dans des avantages
qui pour moi ne l'est point mais pour
certains ça peut noter que plus aucun
contact avec ton cliniciens ou presque
c'est d'un côté rendu un ancien manager
aujourd'hui de plus en plus d'appareils
sophistiqués apparaissent sur le marché
de la santé connectés par exemple la
nouvelle montre à pau watch équipés de
véritables électrocardiogramme qu'on
peut activer du bout du doigt pour
ensuite partager le résultat avec son
cardiologue
une étude récente indique par ailleurs
que plus du quart des canadiens
possèdent un objet connecté
celui ci ça avant tout à suivre leur
activité physique leurs nutrition ou
leur sommeil mais aussi assurer un suivi
médical
est ce que toutes ces nouvelles
informations peuvent être utiles pour le
patient son médecin et le réseau de
santé empressé oui le système de santé
aujourd'hui en particulier au québec a
besoin d'avoir une partie de
de soins qui se fait à domicile ou qui
se fait sur les lieux de vie des
personnes n'est pas obligatoirement
devenir toujours dans les hôpitaux
l'envers de la médaille c'est que
certains patients peuvent se sentir
isolé il ya des patients surtout les
plus âgés qui soudainement se demande
pourquoi qui voient plus leur médecin
est-ce qui va le plus occupé de moi
le cardiologue francs soit on nous
reconnaît que c'est un jeu important
c'est vrai que c'est un danger auquel il
faut veiller parce que on ne veut pas se
retrouver avec un médecin cacher
derrière ces écrans d'ordinateur et puis
un patient qui lève la main au dessus en
disant hé oh je suis là j'aimerais bien
vous parler ici norma grondin radio
canada montréal